well thank you President Aaron for that
that was lovely and uh chairman Sajak
thank you thanks everyone for inviting
me the trustees and the faculty the
administrators here it's uh it's a
thrill to be here at Hillsdale College
which I've heard about for a long time
it's my first visit here came last night
had a wonderful dinner a tour of the
campus and then the culmination of the
evening was this remarkable concert in
the chapel which ended with mahler's
First Symphony played by our student
Orchestra here and it was just really
marvelous so it's been a terrific visit
to Hillsdale I know it might be on the
minds of some I heard people actually
talking and writing about this before I
came here is why would this historically
even famously Protestant College invite
a Catholic bishop of all people to give
the commencement address well I Applause
you for your ecumenical openness but let
me say this
I talked a course in the Reformation for
many years when I was a theology
professor
read The Works of Luther and Calvin the
other reformers with great interest and
I do think the questions they raised
these great 16th century questions that
still divide the churches are important
but I always say this when I'm in a
conversation with my ecumenical friends
right now the needful thing is not
debating those questions so much because
right now all of us who believe in God
all of us who are Disciples of the Lord
Jesus Christ have a common enemy and
we've got to make common cause
I'm talking about this
agnosticism atheism and their attendant
nihilism which are deeply affecting our
culture and especially the minds of
younger people
and I think it's very important for us
to join together in this common cause
against that common enemy and so it's
very much in that spirit that I come
before you today
can I just Echo too what the president
said to all the graduates and it's a
great day for you and congratulations to
you we're proud of you a word of thanks
to the faculty the administrators who've
made this college very impressive place
in our American culture so
congratulations to all of you also to
the parents it's been said but I'll say
it again it's a great day for you you
who have contributed so mightily to
these young people coming to this day
it's a day of celebration for all of us
well it's a permanent honor of this
college that it was founded more than
170 Years Ago by Free Will Baptists
committed to the abolition of slavery
your Founders were on the right side of
the most compelling moral debate of the
19th century and it's worth remarking
that the leadership of the college today
finds itself on the right side of the
most pressing ethical argument of our
time namely the protection of The Unborn
Frederick Douglass a former slave who
became the most eloquent advocate for
abolition in the 19th century spoke here
as you know in 1863 just after the
issuance of the Emancipation
Proclamation
in the course of his lecture which was
entitled popular error and unpopular
truth he remarked and I'm quoting
there's no such thing as new truths
error might be old or new but truth is
as old as the universe close quote
at the heart of the curriculum at
Hillsdale College is a presentation of
those truths
epistemic moral and aesthetic that are
indeed as old as the universe
these permanent things that participate
in the eternity of God
now what I want to do in very brief
compass in this Commencement Address is
to examine just one of those truths
the articulation of which occurs over
and again in the Great Western
intellectual tradition
it's excess typically by means of a
question
not the question of what we are to do as
important as that is but rather what
kind of person we ought to be
do we hunger and thirst for
righteousness
or do we seek our own advantage
in a way and I'll say it especially to
the graduates there's no question in the
moral and spiritual order more
fundamental than that
now a Locus classicus for the
entertainment of this question is in
Plato's dialogue the gorgeous
gorgeous and his friends paulus and
caloquies are suffice
which is to say experts in teaching the
art of persuasive speech
their concern is not being truthful or
just but rather in instructing students
how to speak in such a way that they
appear truthful and just and hence
become convincing to others
such professors were obviously enough
enormously useful to prospective lawyers
and politicians in ancient Greece and it
should be equally obvious that their
intellectual descendants are rather
thick on the ground today
now Socrates counters this office along
these lines
if a rhetorician teaches a politician to
do what in fact is unjust he does that
man and his City far more harm than good
but Paul is Answers by means of a taunt
wouldn't Socrates leap at the
opportunity of having power over life
and death
no says the philosopher in response for
to put someone to death unjustly is in
fact no power at all
and it is at this point that Socrates
enunciates one of his most enduring
teachings representing a watershed in
the moral consciousness of the West
it is better he says to suffer
wrongdoing than to do wrong oneself
it's better to suffer wrongdoing than to
do wrong oneself
at this point California calculus can no
longer restrain himself giving voice
with admirable Clarity to a position
that endures very much to the present
day the Safa says that what Socrates is
calling justice is nothing but the
constraints placed on the few Strong by
the many weak
it's a sort of guilt trip imposed by the
powerless to limit the capacity of the
powerful to get what they want
if you notice a tight connection between
this point of view and the philosophy of
Friedrich Nietzsche you're not wrong
Socrates argument for his position is
simple
surely suffering Injustice is terrible
but what is far worse is the corrosion
of soul that takes place when one
commits an injustice
in other words being unjust is far more
damaging to the moral structure of one's
personality than enduring the slings and
arrows visited upon one by the Injustice
of someone else
so there's the question young brothers
and sisters my fellow graduates today
what kind of soul will you have
what kind of person will you be
will you do whatever it takes to get
what you want
or will you accept even great suffering
in order to do what is right
everything else in your life will flow
from how you answer that question
I know that Hillsdale College is
committed to the study of the Graco
Roman intellectual tradition and it's
for this reason that I commenced with
Plato
but you're also an above all committed
to the scriptures
the Bible gets at this very same issue
but it does so not so much through
philosophical argumentation as through
the prophetic language of idolatry and
right worship
for the biblical authors it's never a
question of religion versus secularism
first of all they were not trading what
we call religion and secondly they knew
that there really is no pure secularism
rather they understood that the world is
basically divided between those who
worship the true God
and those who indulge in idolatry or
false worship
Even in our supposedly secular society
we can appreciate the appropriateness of
the biblical terminology for everyone
even the most secular the most
unchurched operates under the Aegis of
something he or she considers Supreme
some sumam bonum some highest good
no one would in fact get out of bed in
the morning unless he believed in some
value that's ultimately motivating his
actions and decisions
now this might be bodily pleasure or
fame or material Goods or one's country
or one's family but if it's functioning
as the prime mover of a person's
activity it's playing the role of God
and is being effectively worshiped
so the biblical form of the question
that we've been considering is
whom or what do you worship
what's the highest value for you
again graduates everything else in your
life
will flow from how you answer that
question
there are a numberless Biblical texts
that would be odd REM here but I'd like
to look at a particularly clarifying and
dramatic one namely the scene described
in the first book of Kings regarding
Elijah and the priests about all
we recall the setting
Elijah had challenged King Ahab for his
worship of false gods proposed by his
wife Jezebel
he subsequently challenged the avatars
of those deities to a kind of duel on
Mount Carmel
standing alone against the 450 devotees
of ba'al he proposed that he and they
should erect altars to their respective
deities and see who would respond
all morning long the priest cried out
I'm quoting out from the scripture
answer us
but there was no voice
and there was no answer
at this point Elijah mocked them again
I'm quoting from the scriptures cry
aloud surely he's a God either he's
meditating or he's wandered away or he's
on a journey perhaps he's asleep and
must be awakened close quote
then in their frenzy and frustration the
priests of all proceeded to cut
themselves with swords and lances until
the blood gushed over them
but it was to no avail
then of course Elijah calls out to the
Lord and the fire falls consuming the
sacrifice and vindicating the prophet
now I want to emphasize this is much
more than simply a jingoistic story of
my God's bigger than your God
in point effect it's an incomparably
Rich presentation of the Dynamics of
true and false worship
the altar erected to Baal should be
taken as standing for all the ways in
which we order the infinite longing of
our hearts to something less than God
when we do this and fellow sinners in
this space we all know this when we do
this the fire never Falls because merely
worldly things cannot even in principle
satisfy our hungry Souls
and furthermore when we persist in
worshiping falsely we find ourselves in
short order caught in an addictive
pattern
hopping as it were obsessively around
the altars of pleasure or power or fame
Desperately Seeking a satisfaction that
will never come
the self-harm inflicted by the hapless
priests about all speaks eloquently to
the self-destructive quality to which
any addict can attest and all of us
sinners are addicts
only when the fondest desire of our soul
is directed to the infinite God will the
Fire Fall
and addiction be avoided
so once again my young friends my fellow
graduates the question is simple
at which altar will you worship
your whole life will unfold for wheel or
for woe from that decision
now if we want to see the place where
Plato and Elijah come together we need
look no further than the cross of Jesus
which Saint Paul described as a Divine
weakness stronger than human strength
and a Divine Folly wiser than human
wisdom
where could we find a clear
instantiation of the principle that it's
better to suffer Injustice than to
commit it than in Jesus crucifying
sinless blameless he nevertheless took
upon himself all the sin of the world
hatred cruelty stupidity violence
institutional corruption betrayal denial
all of it
but rather than lashing out and
answering violence he said
father forgive them they know not what
they do
laboring under the full weight of human
Injustice and wickedness his soul
remained and violet
and that's why to the consternation of
all the Advocates of Might makes right
from calistities to Nietzsche we hold up
the cross and we say again ironically
with Pontius Pilate eche homo
behold the true man
my intellectual hero Saint Thomas
Aquinas said that if we want to live a
happy life
we should love what Jesus loved on the
cross
and despise what Jesus despised on the
now what did he despise
but all those objects of false worship
to which we tend to erect altars
many of us worship wealth
but on the cross he was utterly poor
stripped naked
many of us worship pleasure
but on the cross he was at the limit of
suffering both physical and
psychological many of us worship power
but on the cross he was nailed in place
unable even to move
many of us worship honor but on that
terrible cross he was the object of
scorn and ridicule
in short the crucified lord said no as
radically as possible to the idols
and what did he love on the cross
he loved doing the will of his father
therefore the cross function as the
altar on which the sacrifice of his life
to the father took place and that's why
the fire fell
can I close with a little reflection on
my favorite movie which is Man For All
Seasons that wonderful 1966 film about
Saint Thomas Moore based on Robert
Bolt's play of the same name
I probably first saw it when I was about
15 and I watched it certainly every year
in my life since then showed it to my
students over the years it's shaped my
moral thinking in so many ways
more of course was a man acquainted both
with classical Antiquity and a man in
love with the Lord Jesus
one of the last scenes of the film
depicts the dramatic trial of more under
accusation for high treason
Richard Ridge who was a young man had
been Moore's friend and protege falsely
testifies against him
perjuring himself and practically
guaranteeing that Moore would receive
the penalty of death
as rich as leaving the courtroom Moore
notices that the younger man is wearing
a chain of office
inquiring of the judges what the symbol
at the end of the chain meant Moore
receives the answer I'm quoting Master
Rich has been appointed attorney general
for Wales close quote
more grass dependent and with a look
more pitying than indignant comments
you know Richard it profits a man
nothing to give his soul for the whole
world
but for whales
Moore was not so much blaming rich as
noticing with infinite sadness the kind
of person he had become
a man with a corroded soul
and it might have been otherwise
in a lesser-known scene from earlier in
the film Moore offers Rich a job as a
humble teacher but Rich ambitious for
Glory at the king's court bogs
Moore says you could be a good teacher
perhaps even a great one
his Protege retorts angrily and if I
were Who would know it
the wise more patiently responds
yourself
your friends
your pupils
God
not a bad public that
this exchange actually provides a third
way of asking our question
to which audience finally are you
playing
a lost soul
plays to the endlessly fickle audience
of the world hoping thereby to acquire
the fleeting Goods that the world can
provide the uncorroded soul
place to God and to the Friends of God
seeking to please them alone
Saint John Paul II in his writings on
the moral life
observe that in every particular ethical
Choice a person makes he's doing two
things simultaneously
he's performing a moral act with
definite consequences
and at the same time he's making his own
character
crafting little by little the person
he's becoming
I have The Confident hope
graduates
that your years at Hillsdale College
have prepared you above all to shape
your characters
to become the kind of persons who would
endure Justice
rather than commit Injustice
who would never dream of worshiping at
the altar of an idol
and who wouldn't surrender the Integrity
of your souls
for the whole world
and if you become the persons God
intends you to be
you will succeed in lighting a fire upon
the Earth
God bless you all thank you
thank you